ils pensent tous des tests de te jeter
cette amo fort seulement exact mais
quand même faut qu'on arrive à les
convaincre
ils éprouvent de la gêne les de
l'affection non qu'on écoute de la la la
la la la
non sûrement pas non tu veux pas dire
d'autre
l'étape olten se préparer à voir leur
famille s'agrandir
c'est quoi ça dit on te présente tombe
mais le bébé se préparer à autre chose
nous les bébés on est en pleine crise
les bébés ne reçoivent pas autant
d'amour qu'autrefois
je vous présente notre ennemi mortel le
pavé chiens non vous voyez c'est ça le
problème
vous avez appris quelque chose ninon
avez vous des infos sur les bébés chiens
gentils beitia non jimbo les bébés
chiens sont des moniales stacy relisez
moi vos notes
je ne sais pas dire qu'est ce que ça dit
bonjour on dirait qu'ils sont à leur
petite table de réunion au niveau du g7
c'est atrocement demi je suis le pp
qu'il vous faut pour ce job je sais que
cette mission est capitale pour la
société messieurs caca prout faut que je
m'occupe du gea est mienne mais qui es
tu je suis chargé de mission il n'y a
pas assez d'amour pour tout le monde
mon boulot c'est de trouver pourquoi
même chercher un double expresso et
voici à des bons sushis dans le quartier
je ne tuerai pour un rouleau de tonte
attaqué au sésame
la guerre est déclarée
regarde
car chaque personne regarde les enfants
ont fini par s'entendre c'est formidable
si je loupe cette mission il faudra que
je vive avec toi pour toujours
ok je te donne un coup de main mais
seulement si tu fiche le camp après ça
roule
oui petit zachary monde dont ils
regardent tous ok
prends ça dans le tube comment faire
pour passer de brasles tarder
je n'ai jamais connu une telle
humiliation de toute ma vie
[Musique]
je mettrai pas le costume de marin et
inmet pourquoi t'as qu'à la lumière
qu'est ce que c'est tout ce bruit vous
avez vu comme il est mignon
j'en ai apporté aussi quoi paul
dreamworks baby boss pose ce biscuit
tout de suite les biscuits c'est pour
les gagnants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]